we are going to turn out to that royal
bombshell and now to that bombshell
announcement it is dominating the front
pages across the UK this morning from
brexit to mechs it is the way it's being
described here disappointed hurt angry
incandescent all of those words have
been used to describe the Royal Family's
reaction here to make it an hairy
statement and a royal source tells et
that some members of the royal family
have even called the move selfish
on Wednesday the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex shocked the world and the
monarchy by announcing their plans to
step back as senior members of the royal
family and to work to become financially
independent our source says many members
of the royal family were disappointed
with Meghan in Harry adding that the
Queen is devastated it turns out it's
not so much what they did it's how they
did it
the palace has gone into serious crisis
mode it is on lockdown there are talks
ongoing and they will be ongoing for
many days to come the Sussex is went
nuclear when they issued that statement
the palace weren't ready for it there
are so many things that still need to be
addressed and of course a meeting that
at some point is going to have to happen
between the Queen and her grandson
according to royal expert Katie Nicol
the Sussex is had been in touch with
senior members of the royal family while
they were visiting Canada but
yesterday's announcement wasn't part of
the deal in fact a source tells ET that
the Queen actually asked Harry not to
release his statement on Wednesday but
the Prince defied his grandmother and
did it anyway
this was very early stage discussions
nothing had been signed off nothing had
been decided upon and the idea was it
was going to be developed talked about a
strategy would be worked out and then an
announcement would be made but the
Sussex is appear to have completely
jumped the gun here by announcing this
statement on their website on their
Instagram page and essentially on their
terms and I think that has what has led
to a sense of betrayal at the palace a
sense of anger possibly even fury on the
Queen's part
it's understood that the Queen had
personally asked Prince Harry not to
make any of this public until it had
been agreed signed off and properly
discussed Nikhil also weighed in on how
this affects Prince William and Duchess
Kate there is a big gap that is now
going to need to be filled
that is partly going to have to be
filled by William and Kate so yes I I
suspect that as well as feeling
disappointed and upset and angry at the
way this has all been handled that they
also feel abandoned to what's more the
Sussex is made their announcement one
day before Keith's 38th birthday
deliberate Nicol says probably not but
here's what could have led to the Royals
announcement I think actually it had so
much to do with that front page in the
Sun tabloid newspaper yesterday which
preempted this moved to America which
hinted at the Royals stepping down from
their role and I'm told that the Sussex
is wanted to reclaim that narrative they
wanted to announce it in their own words
on their terms which is very possibly
why they press send and made that
shocking decision to go public with the
news last night I always take my family
and now I have a family to protect all
we need to do is focus focus on on being
real and focus on being the people that
we are and standing up for what we
believe in I will you know I will not I
will not be bullied into into into
playing a game that's that killed my mom
not many people have asked if I'm okay
but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes after a year
of scrutinizing headlines Harry and
Megan seemed to be doing everything they
can to reclaim control of their
narrative but the media may not be the
only reason they've decided to step back
I think it has a lot to do with Harry
wanting to live a more ordinary life and
I think it's crucially about Harry
wanting to protect Archie I know Harry
grew up a little boy whose life was was
very much in the spotlight the press
were there to capture every moment and
it's that level of scrutiny that Harry
has always resented about his life and
has been desperate to protect our chief
from Prince Harry himself has admitted
there are times in his life when he
wished he hadn't been born a prince I
think he's always felt very restricted
by royalty he has felt that he's never
been able to break free and be his own
person I think without a doubt Megan has
given Harry a new confidence I think if
he could have stepped down as the senior
royal some time back I think he probably
would have done but he didn't have he
didn't have the confidence or the
strength to do that he couldn't do that
on his own but but with Megan and as he
slipped down the line of succession and
don't forget he's not the spare anymore
he's sixth in line to the British throne
I think that's given him more latitude
and I think Megan has given him the
confidence to to break free
[Music]